-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
This is "The Tonight Show."
Well, guys,
I want to say congrats
to the Kansas City Chiefs
and Tampa Bay Buccaneers
on advancing to Super Bowl 55.
That is right.
Tom Brady is once again
returning to the Super Bowl.
Man, between Tom Brady
and Joe Biden,
what a month it's been
for 78-year-old white guys.
Yep, Brady will be playing
in his 10th Super Bowl.
How does he keep doing this?
I think he once got stuck making
small talk at a Super Bowl party
and vowed, "I will never put
myself in this position again."
It's like, "I'll just
play in all of them.
If Brady keeps up this pace,
I'm just worried
where he's gonna put
the 11th Super Bowl ring
when he runs out of fingers.
[ Laughter ]
-Aw, no.
-His toe, the big toe, maybe?
-Oh.
[ Laughs ]
-Meanwhile, the Chiefs are going
to their second Super Bowl
in a row,
led by star quarterback
Patrick Mahomes.
He's 25, he's the reigning
Super Bowl MVP,
and he signed a deal
for $500 million.
He might be
the only guy on earth
Tom Brady would
trade places with.
Of course, it's not just
the quarterbacks facing off,
it's also the coaches.
The Chiefs are led by Andy Reid.
The Buccaneers are led
by Bruce Arians.
Can we see them both?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like
a before and before photo.
[ Laughter ]
Kind of strange that we've never
seen them at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
The only thing
we know for sure --
the winning coach will be
red, white, and round.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, the Kool-Aid man is
like, "I'm so torn. Oh, yeah!"
And this is cool, the Buccaneers
will be the first team ever
to play a Super Bowl
in their home stadium.
Apparently, the Bucs saw the
entire world working from home
and thought, "Eh, why not us?"
One NBA team is allowing
a limited number of fans
back into their arena this week,
and they've come up
with a unique way
to keep people safe
from the virus. Listen to this.
-The Miami Heat will use
specially-trained dogs
to sniff fans for COVID.
If the dog sits, that signals
they may have
detected the virus,
and fans will be asked to leave.
-Yeah, these dogs
are super smart.
They can tell whether you have
coronavirus, drugs,
or a counterfeit ticket
from StubHub.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the Miami Heat
will use COVID-sniffing dogs
to screen fans at games, which
brings us to our new segment,
"Uhh...I Have Some Questions."
-♪ Uhh...I Have Some Questions ♪
-First up, since when are there
dogs that can "sniff" COVID?
[ Laughter ]
Next up, if a dog "sniffs"
COVID, won't it get COVID?
[ Laughter ]
Follow-up. Can dogs get COVID?
If they can,
and a common symptom of COVID
is loss of smell,
how can you trust a dog
to properly smell more COVID?
[ Laughter, applause ]
Also, are these the same dogs
that sniff for bombs
at the airport,
or are they completely
different dogs?
If they're the same dogs, are
they getting paid overtime pay?
I just have so many questions.
-♪ I just have
so many questions ♪
-Speaking of dogs, yesterday,
President Biden's dogs,
Champ and Major,
moved into the White House.
Yep, some dogs get to live
in the White House,
while others have to
sniff for COVID.
[ Laughter ]
Not only are Biden's dogs
at the White House,
they're sleeping
in the same dog house
that Dr. Fauci was in
all of last year.
[ Laughter ]
The dogs are actually
pretty busy.
They're now in charge
of the Space Force.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Major hasn't even
been there a full day,
and he's already passed
an executive order
that allows you
to lick yourself in public.
Unbelievable.
Some entertainment news.
Yesterday, HBO Max released
the first look of the new
"Godzilla vs. Kong" movie
that comes out in March.
It looks insane.
Check out part of the trailer.
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Come on, oh, here we go ♪
♪ Give it a hundred,
never nothin' less, here we go ♪
-The only thing
more fun than that movie
is imagining two guys
in spandex suits
acting that out
in front of a green screen.
[ Laughter ]
Godzilla and King Kong fight
each other the whole movie,
but I'm told it's
the make-up sex near the end
that got them the R rating.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal playing ]
This is going viral.
A "Bridgerton" fan
spotted a modern-day mistake
in one of the opening scenes.
Take a look at this.
Can you guys tell what's wrong?
Here it is. Yeah.
The show is set in the 1800s,
but there's a yellow line that's
only used on modern roads.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think
it's that big of a deal.
-I do.
It pulls me
out of the trance, man.
If you want me
to watch your show,
then you can't be showing things
that people didn't use
or have in that era.
[ Telephone rings ]
-Sorry, what is that?
Is someone's phone on?
-Yeah, sorry, man,
I got to take this.
I've been on hold
for like an hour.
Hello?
Netflix?
-Oh, God. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah, cancel my subscription.
You know why!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh. Alright.
Let's move on. Alright.
Listen to this. An inventor
n Sweden has created something
to help keep
motorcycle riders safe.
-Airbag jeans.
These pants have concealed
airbags inside the legs.
And if riders fall,
the airbags are triggered
and filled up
with compressed air.
-Yeah, it's great
until you hit a small bump
and suddenly
turn into MC Hammer.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a volcanic rock
was discovered in Brazil
that looks like Cookie Monster,
and it could be worth
more than $10,000.
Check this out.
Yeah.
10 grand.
Right now, people are at home
with blue paint and a Sharpie
like, "Yeah, this rock also
looks like Cookie Monster."
[ Laughter, applause ]
Sorry, I'm just realizing how
different our monologue is now.
Our last two stories were about
inflatable pants
and Cookie Monster.